I like the energy that's what I'm
talking about
and that's the kind of energy I would
expect for the first time walking like a
red carpet or pink carpet in America man
this is a big deal for you guys what's
how exciting I mean it's like still we
cannot believe it like is it dreamy like
such a good ones oh yeah it's crazy
bill boy yeah
[Applause]
you're also obviously like a fan voted
category up against the powerhouses I
mean like it's no joke you guys are up
against move we got like Bieber's in
there you got someone I mean this is and
you guys are killing it I mean people
are vote people love you out there come
on man no like that's this it's all you
know like we take you know we give our
glory to all of the armies like you know
we're fans you know we saw the twits
like millions and you know millions so
like we're so thankful for that a lot of
people excited that you guys are here
obviously who are you excited to see
tonight gentlemen John Legend's got John
Legend okay great all right we got Drake
Nicki mean Ozzy Minaj Bogart smoke Jim
Red John John Lackey Krueger Jason that
arose hey they're all you chain smokers
smokers all right boom
[Music]
you